parlons de ce qui ne changera jamais dans la narration.
Shonda Rhimes : Ce qui ne changera jamais.
Je pense que les bonnes histoires ne changeront jamais,
le besoin des gens de se réunir et d'échanger leurs histoires,
de parler des choses qui semblent universelles,
nous avons tous un irrésistible besoin de regarder,
de raconter, de partager des histoires --
en quelque sorte, se réunir autour du feu
pour discuter des choses qui nous indiquent tous
que nous ne sommes pas seuls au monde.
Pour moi, ces choses ne changeront jamais.
Cette essence de la narration ne changera jamais.
CS : En préparation à cette conversation,
j'ai discuté avec Susan Lyne
qui dirigeait ABC Entertainment
quand vous travailliez sur « Grey's Anatomy »
SR : Oui.
CS : Elle m'a dit qu'elle avait ce souvenir indélébile,
quand vous distribuiez les rôles,
sans en discuter avec les exécutifs,
vous faisiez venir des gens pour lire vos scripts
et chacun d'entre eux était un éventail complet de l'humanité,
vous n'en supprimiez aucun des scripts
et c'était très surprenant.
Elle a dit qu'en plus de recycler les exécutifs du studio,
elle avait l'impression,
et je suis d'accord,
que vous réformiez les attentes du public américain.
Qu'y a-t-il d'autre dont le public ne réalise pas encore qu'il a besoin ?
SR : Ce qu'il ne réalise pas encore ?
Je crois que nous ne sommes pas encore là.
Nous sommes toujours
très, très loin de ce à quoi ressemble le monde réel.
Je ne faisais pas venir quelques acteurs
qui étaient très différents les uns des autres
simplement pour prouver quelque chose
et je ne souhaitais rien faire de spécial.
Il ne m'est jamais venu à l'esprit que c'était nouveau, différent ou bizarre.
J'ai fait venir des acteurs car je les trouvais intéressants
et l'idée que c'était très surprenant pour tout le monde,
je l'ignorais.
Je pensais que c'étaient les acteurs que je voulais voir jouer.
Je voulais les voir lire.
Ensuite, on verrait.
Je crois que ce qui est intéressant
c'est que regarder le monde d'un nouveau point de vue,
quand vous n'êtes pas la personne responsable,
le monde perçu est différent.
CS : Vous dirigez maintenant cette grosse machine
en tant que titan, comme dit l'année dernière,
c'est un titan.
A votre avis, que va-t-il se passer ?
Il y d'énormes sommes d'argent investies dans la production de ces séries.
Si les outils pour créer des histoires se sont fortement démocratisées,
cette large distribution persiste :
des gens qui louent des réseaux, qui louent le public à des publicitaires
et en retirent de l'argent.
Comment voyez-vous le modèle commercial changer
maintenant que n'importe qui peut être un narrateur ?
SR : Ça change chaque jour.
Le changement très rapide qui se produit est génial.
Et j'ai l'impression -- la panique est palpable
et je ne dis pas ça négativement.
Je trouve ça excitant.
L'idée qu'il y ait une sorte d'égalisateur,
ça signifie que n'importe qui peut créer quelque chose, c'est merveilleux.
L'idée selon laquelle on ne peut pas trouver le bon travail est effrayante.
Il y a tant de travail.
Il y a environ 417 drames qui passent à la télévision
n'importe quand et n'importe où, mais les trouver est impossible.
Impossible de trouver les bons.
Il y en a plein de mauvais
car tout le monde peut créer quelque chose.
Comme si tout le monde peignait une peinture.
Il n'y a pas tant de bons peintres.
Trouver les bonnes histoires, les bonnes séries,
c'est de plus en plus difficile.
Car s'il y a une petite série sur AMC
et une autre sur une autre chaîne,
trouver où elles sont devient plus difficile.
Dénicher les perles rares
et découvrir qui a réalisé le super webisode ou un autre,
je pense aux pauvres critiques
qui passent 24 heures par jour
enfermés chez eux à tout regarder.
Actuellement, ce n'est pas un boulot facile.
Les machines de distribution deviennent de plus en plus vastes,
mais trouver la bonne programmation pour tout le public
devient plus difficile.
Contrairement aux informations,
où tout est réduit à qui vous êtes,
la télévision semble devenir --
par télévision je parle de tout ce que vous pouvez regarder, les séries --
semble s'élargir de plus en plus.
Tout le monde compose des histoires
et les génies sont parfois cachés.
Mais ça devient plus dur à trouver
et, à un moment donné, ça s'effondrera.
On parle du « pic » de la télé.
J'ignore quand ça arrivera.
Je crois qu'à un moment ça s'effondrera un peu
et nous nous réunirons de nouveau.
J'ignore si ce sera un réseau de télévision.
J'ignore si ce modèle est durable.
CS : Qu'en est-il du modèle
dans lequel Amazon et Netflix dépensent beaucoup d'argent ?
SR : C'est vrai.
C'est un modèle intéressant.
Il a quelque chose d'excitant.
Pour les créateurs de contenu, il a quelque chose d'excitant.
Pour le monde, il a quelque chose d'excitant.
Le fait qu'il y ait des programmes
pouvant être en de multiples langues avec des personnages du monde entier
qui sont intéressants et sortent pour tout le monde en même temps,
c'est excitant.
Le côté international que la télévision peut maintenant revêtir
a du sens à mes yeux,
la programmation peut revêtir ce côté.
La télévision est bien plus faite -- voici notre public américain.
Nous créons ces séries
et ensuite nous les envoyons dans le monde
en espérant le meilleur,
au lieu de vraiment penser qu'il n'y a pas que l'Amérique.
Nous nous aimons, mais il n'y a pas que l'Amérique.
Nous devrions prendre en compte le fait
qu'il y a tous ces autres endroits à travers le monde
auxquels nous devrions nous intéresser pour raconter des histoires.
Nous réduisons le monde.
Je ne sais pas.
Ça fait avancer l'idée que le monde est un endroit universel
et nos histoires deviennent universelles.
Nous arrêtons d'être autre.
CS : Vous êtes pionnière, de ce que je peux voir,
de façon intéressante de lancer de nouvelles séries.
Quand vous avez lancé « Scandal » en 2012,
vous avez reçu un soutien incroyablement large sur Twitter,
quelque chose de jamais vu auparavant.
Avez-vous d'autres tours dans votre manche
pour quand vous lancerez votre prochaine série ?
A votre avis, que se passera-t-il ?
SR : Nous avons des idées intéressantes.
Nous avons une série, « Still Star-Crossed », qui sort cet été
et nous avons des idées intéressantes.
J'ignore si nous pourrons les mettre en œuvre à temps.
Je les trouve amusantes.
Mais l'idée d'envoyer des tweets en direct
était une idée que nous trouvions amusante.
Nous n'avions pas réalisé que les critiques se joindraient à nous.
Mais les fans -- que les gens participent,
en faisant plus un feu de camp --
quand vous êtes ensemble sur Twitter
et parlez ensemble,
c'est une expérience partagée
et trouver d'autres façons de rendre ça possible
et faire participer les gens
est important.
CS : Quand vous avez tous ces gens créant des histoires
et que seuls certains vont percer
et avoir un public,
comment les narrateurs vont-ils être payés ?
SR : Je me débats également avec ce concept.
Est-ce que ce sera un modèle d'abonnement ?
Est-ce que les gens diront qu'ils veulent regarder les séries d'une personne
et ça fonctionnera ainsi ?
CS : Nous devrions acheter un passeport pour Shondaland.
SR : Je ne sais pas, mais oui. C'est beaucoup plus de travail pour moi.
Il y aura plusieurs façons de faire,
mais j'ignore lesquelles.
Pour être honnête, beaucoup de créateurs de contenu
ne sont pas intéressés par le fait d'être des distributeurs,
parce que ce que je rêve de faire
c'est créer du contenu.
J'adore créer du contenu.
Je veux être payée pour ça
et je veux être payée la somme que je mérite pour ça
mais c'est difficile à trouver.
Je veux aussi que ce soit possible
pour les gens travaillant avec moi,
les gens travaillant pour moi,
pour tout le monde d'être payé de manière à gagner sa vie.
La manière dont c'est distribué devient de plus en plus complexe.
Qu'en est-il des nombreux outils,
la réalité virtuelle, la réalité augmentée...
Je trouve ça fascinant qu'il ne soit pas possible de se gaver de télévision,
d'utiliser l'avance rapide avec ces choses-là.
Comment voyez-vous l'avenir de ces choses pour la narration ?
SR : Au cours de l'année, j'ai passé beaucoup de temps
à explorer ces choses-là,
à suivre plein de démonstrations et à être attentive.
Je les trouve fascinantes,
en grande partie car je pense --
la majorité des gens les considèrent pour jouer,
pour des choses comme de l'action
et je pense qu'il y a une intimité
qui est très présente dans ces choses-là,
l'idée que -- imaginez,
vous pouvez être assis là et avoir une conversation avec Fitz
ou du moins que Fitz vous parle,
le président Fitzgerald Grant III,
que Fitz vous parle
du pourquoi il a pris cette décision
et c'est un moment très profond.
Au lieu de regarder sur un écran de télévision,
vous êtes assis à côté de lui et avez une conversation.
Vous tombez amoureux de l'homme
alors qu'il parle depuis un écran de télé.
Imaginez être assis à côté de lui
ou être avec un personnage comme Huck qui va tuer quelqu'un.
Au lieu d'avoir une scène
où il parle très vite à un autre personnage,
il va dans un placard, se tourne vers vous et il vous dit
ce qu'il va se passer et pourquoi il a peur et est nerveux.
C'est plus proche du théâtre, j'ignore si ça marcherait
mais je suis fascinée par le concept d'une telle chose
et ce que ça signifierait pour le public.
Jouer avec ces idées serait très intéressant
et pour mon public, les gens regardant mes séries,
les femmes entre 12 et 75 ans,
il y a là quelque chose d'intéressant pour elles.
CS : Et la participation du public ?
Êtes-vous intéressée par les choses
où le public peut aller jusqu'à un certain point
puis décider, choisir sa propre aventure.
Je vais m'enfuir avec Fitz ou je vais m'enfuir avec --
SR : Les histoires où l'on choisit son aventure.
J'ai du mal avec ça,
pas nécessairement parce que je veux tout contrôler,
mais parce que quand je regarde la télévision ou un film,
je sais qu'une histoire ne sera pas aussi bonne
si j'ai le contrôle de ce qu'il va se passer
pour un autre personnage.
Si je pouvais vous dire exactement
ce que je veux qu'il arrive à Walter White,
c'est très bien mais l'histoire n'est pas la même, pas aussi forte.
Si je suis responsable de la fin des « Soprano »,
c'est sympathique et j'ai une fin qui est bien et satisfaisante,
mais ce n'est pas la même histoire ni le même impact émotionnel.
CS : Je ne peux pas m'empêcher d'imaginer ce que ce serait.
Désolée, vous m'avez perdue un instant.
SR : C'est merveilleux que je ne puisse pas l'imaginer
car Vince a sa propre fin
et savoir ce que quelqu'un d'autre a dit rend ça très fort.
Si vous pouviez décider
que dans « Les dents de la mer », les requins gagnent,
ça n'a pas l'effet que ça devrait sur vous.
L'histoire est l'histoire racontée,
vous pouvez partir en colère, vous pouvez en débattre
et vous pouvez en discuter,
c'est pour ça que ça marche. C'est pour ça que c'est de l'art.
Autrement, ce n'est qu'un jeu
et les jeux peuvent être de l'art mais de façon bien différente.
CS : Les joueurs qui vendent le droit d'être assis là
et de commenter ce qu'il se passe,
pour moi c'est plus une communauté que de la narration.
SR : C'est une sorte de feu de camp.
Je n'écarte pas cette forme de narration,
mais ça se fait en groupe.
CS : Qu'en est-il des super super --
du fait que tout devient de plus en plus court ?
Snapchat a une chose appelée « série »
qui dure une minute.
SR : Intéressant.
Une partie de moi pense que ça ressemble à des pubs.
Quelque chose de sponsorisé.
Mais une autre partie de moi comprend tout à fait.
Il y a là quelque chose de merveilleux.
Si vous pensez au monde
où la plupart des gens regardent la télé sur leur téléphone,
si vous pensez à un endroit comme l'Inde
d'où viennent la plupart des contributions, des produits,
ça a du sens.
Si vous pouvez faire payer plus pour du contenu plus court,
un distributeur a découvert un moyen de gagner beaucoup d'argent.
Si vous créez du contenu,
ça coûte moins cher de le créer et de le rendre accessible.
Au passage,
si, comme ma fille, vous avez 14 ans et une capacité de concentration courte,
c'est ce que vous voulez voir, ce que vous voulez créer,
c'est ainsi que ça marche.
Si vous le faites bien et que ça ressemble à un récit,
les gens resteront en ligne, peu importe ce que vous faites.
CS : Je suis contente que vous ayez élevé vos filles
car je me demande comment elles consommeront du divertissement
et pas que du divertissement,
les actualités également.
Les chefs suprêmes robotiques et algorithmiques
vont les nourrir de ce qu'ils ont déjà fait.
A votre avis, comment corrigerons-nous ça
et ferons des citoyens équilibrés ?
SR : Ma façon de le corriger
est très différente de celle de quelqu'un d'autre.
CS : N'hésitez pas à spéculer.
SR : Je ne sais pas vraiment comment nous le ferons à l'avenir.
Mes pauvres enfants ont été les sujets de toutes mes expériences.
Nous pratiquons encore les « étés amish »
où j'éteins tous nos appareils,
je range tous leurs ordinateurs et autres
et je les regarde hurler un moment avant qu'ils ne se calment
et vivent un été sans appareils électroniques.
Honnêtement, c'est un monde difficile
dans lequel, en tant qu'adultes,
nous nous intéressons tant à regarder notre propre truc
et nous ignorons même que l'on nous nourrit, parfois,
de nos propres opinions.
Aujourd'hui, ça fonctionne ainsi :
vous regardez des actualités
et elles sont corrigées
afin que vous ne receviez que vos opinions
et que vous vous sentiez de plus en plus sûr de vous.
Comment discerner les choses ?
Ça devient inquiétant.
Peut-être qu'il y aura de la surcorrection ou une explosion
ou nous deviendrons tous --
je déteste être négative,
mais peut-être deviendrons-nous tous un peu plus idiots.
(Cyndi rit)
CS : Pouvez-vous imaginer des rectifications que vous pourriez faire
avec du travail écrit, fictif ?
SR : Je réfléchis beaucoup au fait que la télévision a le pouvoir
d'éduquer les gens efficacement
et quand vous regardez la télévision --
par exemple, il y a des études sur les séries médicales.
Je crois que 87% des gens
tirent leurs connaissances sur la médecine et les faits médicaux
des séries médicales,
bien plus qu'ils ne les tirent de leurs médecins ou d'articles.
Nous travaillons dur à être exacts et quand nous commettons une erreur,
je me sens coupable, comme si nous agissions mal.
Nous donnons beaucoup de bonnes informations médicales.
Il y a tant d'alternatives pour fournir des informations.
Les gens sont divertis.
Peut-être ne veulent-ils pas lire l'actualité,
mais il y a des façons d'offrir des informations justes avec ces séries,
pas de façon sinistre, en voulant contrôler l'esprit des gens,
mais d'une façon intéressante et intelligente,
sans pencher d'un côté ou de l'autre,
en offrant la vérité.
Il serait étrange, cependant,
si les drames télévisés étaient notre façon de présenter les actualités.
CS : Ce serait étrange
mais beaucoup de ce que vous avez écrit en tant que fiction
s'est transformé en prédiction cette saison.
SR : « Scandal » a été très perturbante pour cette raison.
Nous avons cette série sur la politique qui sombre dans la folie
et nous avons toujours raconté cette série --
tout le monde s'intéresse aux journaux.
Nous lisons tout. Nous parlons de tout.
Nous avons beaucoup d'amis à Washington.
Cette série a toujours été pleine de spéculations.
Nous réfléchissions à ce qu'il se passerait
si le bus perdait ses roues et que tout sombrait dans la folie.
C'était toujours génial,
sauf qu'on avait l'impression que le bus perdait ses roues
et que tout sombrait dans la folie,
les choses sur lesquelles nous spéculions devenaient réalité.
Notre saison cette année
allait finir avec les Russes contrôlant les élections américaines,
nous l'avions écrit et prévu,
tout était là,
puis les Russes ont été suspectés d'être impliqués dans l'élection américaine
et nous avons soudainement dû changer ce que nous allions faire.
J'ai dit :
« Cette scène où notre femme mystère parle russe ?
Nous devons arranger ça et trouver ce que nous allons faire. »
Ce n'étaient que des extrapolations
de ce que nous pensions qu'il allait se passer
ou ce que nous trouvions fou.
CS : C'est génial.
Où regardez-vous en plus de Washington, aux Etats-Unis ou ailleurs ?
Qui raconte une histoire intéressante actuellement ?
SR : Il y a beaucoup de choses intéressantes.
La télévision britannique est toujours extraordinaire
et fait toujours des choses intéressantes.
Je ne regarde pas beaucoup la télévision,
surtout parce que je suis occupée avec mon travail.
J'essaye de ne pas trop regarder la télévision,
même la télévision américaine, avant d'avoir fini une saison,
car sinon tout ça s'insinue dans ma tête.
Et après je me demande
pourquoi nos personnages n'ont pas de couronne et ne parlent pas d'un trône.
Ça devient fou.
Je ne regarde pas grand chose avant la fin de nos saisons.
Mais je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de télévision européenne intéressante.
J'étais aux Emmy internationaux,
j'ai regardé ce qu'ils présentaient
et j'ai été fascinée.
Il y a des choses que je veux regarder.
CS : Pouvez-vous imaginer --
vous ne passez pas beaucoup de temps à penser à la technologie,
mais il y a quelques années nous avons eu quelqu'un à TED
parlant de voir,
de porter des Google Glass et de voir vos séries dans votre œil.
Vous arrive-t-il de rêver --
la petite fille qui s'asseyait dans le garde-manger
chez ses parents --
avez-vous déjà imaginé un autre support ?
Ou l'imagineriez-vous maintenant ?
SR : Un autre support.
Pour la narration, à part les livres ?
En grandissant, je voulais être Toni Morrison donc non.
Je ne pensais même pas à la télévision.
L'idée qu'il pourrait y avoir un monde plus vaste,
une façon plus magique de créer des choses --
la sortie d'une technologie m’enthousiasme
et je suis toujours la première à vouloir l'essayer.
Les possibilités semblent infinies et excitantes actuellement,
ça m'enthousiasme.
J'ai l'impression que nous sommes dans une période du Far West
car personne ne sait ce que nous allons choisir.
Vous pouvez créer des histoires partout,
à mon sens, c'est cool,
et j'ai l'impression qu'une fois qu'on aura découvert
comment réunir la technologie et la créativité de la narration,
les possibilités sont sans fin.
CS : La technologie a permis des choses que j'ai évoquées plus tôt,
le gavage de séries, qui est un phénomène récent
depuis que vous réalisez des séries.
Pensez-vous que ça change le processus de narration ?
Vous avez toujours eu une bible pour toute la saison au préalable, non ?
SR : Non, j'ai juste toujours su où nous allions finir.
Pour moi,
Mon seul commentaire à ce sujet
est que j'ai une série qui dure depuis 14 saisons
et il y a donc des gens qui la regardent depuis 14 saisons
et puis il y a des filles de 12 ans que je rencontre au supermarché
et qui ont regardé 297 épisodes en trois semaines.
Sérieusement, elles ont une expérience très différente,
elles ont été au cœur de quelque chose
de façon très intense sur une période très courte,
de façon très intense,
et pour elles l'histoire décrit un arc très différent
et a un sens complètement différent
car il n'y a jamais eu de pauses.
CS : C'est comme visiter un pays puis en partir, c'est un étrange --
SR : C'est comme lire un super roman puis poser le livre.
C'est la beauté de l'expérience.
Il n'y a pas forcément besoin de regarder 14 saisons d'une série.
Tout n'est pas forcément censé être ainsi.
CS : A votre avis, y a-t-il un sujet que nous ne devrions pas toucher ?
SR : Je ne pense pas voir les histoires ainsi.
Je vois les histoires en termes de personnages, ce qu'ils devraient faire,
ce qu'ils doivent faire pour faire avancer.
Je ne pense jamais à une histoire juste en termes d'intrigue
et quand des scénaristes viennent me présenter une intrigue,
je dis : « Vous ne parlez pas français ».
Voilà ce que je dis.
Ce n'est pas du français. Je dois entendre ce qui est réel.
Je ne vois pas ça ainsi.
J'ignore s'il y a moyen de savoir s'il y a une chose que je ne ferais pas
car c'est comme si j'arrachais des bouts d'intrigue d'un mur.
CS : C'est génial. A quel point pensez-vous utiliser --
Vous avez rejoint le comité de direction du planning familial
et vous êtes investie dans la campagne d'Hillary Clinton.
A quel point pensez-vous utiliser votre narration
dans le monde réel
pour faire changer les choses ?
SR : Il y a --
C'est un sujet intense à mes yeux
car je trouve que le manque de narration
chez beaucoup de gens est difficile.
Il y a beaucoup d'organisations
qui ne se sont pas créées de récit positif
qui les aiderait.
Il y a beaucoup de campagnes
qui pourraient être aidées grâce à un meilleur récit.
Les démocrates pourraient faire beaucoup de choses
avec un récit très fort.
Beaucoup de choses pourraient se produire
en termes de voix de narration
et je ne le dis pas en termes de fiction
mais plutôt dans les mêmes termes qu'un rédacteur de discours.
Je le vois
mais j'ignore si c'est mon travail de faire ça.
CS : Très bien.
Aidez-moi à remercier Shonda. SR : Merci.
(Applaudissements)